they point to a suburban area where they
know everyone's carrying and so people
are there on their best behavior
I don't think there's been a single
major city over the course of two weeks
that has not seemed serious damage and I
won't ask you this cuz you're more
wonkish than I am there are two minds
about this do you think these riots
affect how do you think they affect the
president's chances good bad for
reelection I think he's got to show that
he can step up and stop them you know I
like that president Trump is I think
he's taking the right tone most of the
tweets have been really on message but I
think what a lot of people are looking
at is they're saying okay you're right
about the tweets you're all right about
holding hearings and tweets and things
but you've got to actually do something
and this brings up the real problem that
conservatives have which is
conservatives don't control any of the
institutions you know there's there's
this crazy thing where the left always
talks about institutional racism as
though it's our fault conservatives
fault and I think the left controls
every major institution in the country
the media Hollywood big tech the Academy
on and on the administrative government
everything so if there is institutional
racism whose fault is that
right not to mention the unions and this
is one thing new it's remarkable the
turn because I've talked about this with
John you know John Oliver is doing this
video listen I have consistently been
anti-union
in the 21st century you know I
understand that at one point the
Industrial Revolution there was some guy
a little bit different now since no one
found hafez body times have changed it
is entirely consistent for me and I do
believe this to say hey let's dissolve
the police unions let's change the
structure there so that we can actually
have some accountability just like I do
the same way I feel for teachers unions
we should reward good cops and we should
expel and punish bad cops but it is
entirely inconsistent for the left to in
this instance say they have a problem
with police unions because they are the
ones who protect these unions who by the
way are the biggest political donors in
the country bar none it's not even close
right and it's it's multiple public
sector unions right the police or a
public sector union the teachers are a
public sector union and the left does
very well with these guys you know they
think that when they get rid of the cops
things are going to become more peaceful
obviously that is not the case but there
was one incident in Virginia that to me
is the symbol of the whole thing which
is you know cops to be seen there were
no cops or
and these rioters like they were in
Baghdad in 2003 pulled down a statue
right they they tie around in the neck
pull down the statue and the statue is
it comes tumbling down squishes one of
the rioters and overall just like
everything about this scene is sad but I
think this tells you the whole story
which is that when you pull down your
history you pull down your traditions
and institutions you think it's gonna
free you actually you're gonna get
squished in 2003 was not a good vintage
for Baghdad by the way ever no no to man
no I think it's a valid point and this
is something that was just think about
today maybe you have a strong opinion on
this I haven't heard anyone talk about
it they wanna get rid of police unions
what's going to happen with card check
for people who don't know the left they
don't because many people in unions
don't want to be in unions so the left
wants to make sure that the Union
basically card check means everyone
knows how you voted no private vote and
they say that's to protect the worker
from the intimidating corporate overlord
but really it's the intimidating union
you can't find someone corrupt in the
Teamsters what do you think will happen
here if they want to get rid of police
unions because then there has to be some
kind of a vote or bureaucratic process
with card check they really have their
balls in a twister they do I mean there
there is this great thing we can count
on which is the left's incompetence
that's that's the one saving grace that
we've got here is we could end up in a
world where after all of this insanity
it actually all backfires on the left
and we do really well but we've got to
play it smart here you know and one
thing that I think maybe some
Republicans are messing up right now is
you've got this moment where cities are
literally on fire unions are very
unpopular cops themselves actually
pretty popular and for some reason what
I don't know why conservatives are
attacking Joe Biden for being tough on
crime
they are like trying to grab defeat from
the jaws of victory this is the one time
say no Trump is tough on crime Joe Biden
is not even alive anymore practically
and you'll go weak on crime and yet for
some reason we're making the totally
wrong argument no I think you're you're
right I think there's some validity in
saying hey Joe Biden if you really
believe this why did you not do anything
for the first 50 years of your life but
you actually did the opposite and then
move on your merry way but yeah there is
a little
it does bother me sometimes where you
see and you don't see this so much from
from Trump necessarily or his
administration but from some of his
supporters where they focus more on the
gotcha then you can hit a gotcha right
that's a jab then move on with something
else you know do some footwork here and
let people know where you're coming from
and instead they keep focusing on the
gotcha
yeah but 60 says it 72% we just talked
about if Americans want to send in the
National Guard focus on that do that
that's the thing to do you know and you
make a great point here on Biden which
is Biden's whole campaign is yes we're
so close to making change and progress
and you say well you were the vice
president for eight years you were a
senator for 830 years I mean you've been
truly over half a century in politics
right you didn't do it then you can't do
it now if Trump makes this argument and
say look I've been in politics for three
years now four years I've accomplished
more in that time and more good stuff in
that time than any of my predecessors
reelect me at this moment of chaos and
uncertainty and we'll get some more good
stuff that's a winning message the guy
could win you know 50 states almost